hater react Victor Davis Hanson senior
fellow at Stanford University's Hoover
Institution and author of the
forthcoming book the case for Trump
Howard Kurtz host of media buzz and
Austan Goolsbee former economic adviser
to President Obama so Victor let me
start with you why does President Obama
he's he feels like kin has to always
come out and try to rebrand this
presidency
it seems really insecure they always
kind of claim about Donald Trump's
insecure I mean it seems like it's very
insecure to kind of say well I'm the one
who got all the oil stuff going and I'm
the water did the G when the facts just
frankly are not there in comparing the
two economic records as you see puzzler
do and the journal yesterday yeah I
think there's two points one is the
progressive mindset sees politics is a
360-degree 24/7 operation or job so the
last day in office is the first day of
another progressive a career we saw that
with Jimmy Carter remember he always had
to comment and editorialize and travel
when Reagan was president during the two
Bush's presidencies Al Gore and Bill
Clinton were quite active in criticism
and Obama's doing the same thing for
them it's a non-stop activity and you
know they need to get a ranch he should
go to Hawaii and buy a farm and focus on
Netflix that's what Reagan got when up
to the ranch W went to the ranch and let
his predecessor be and and it's kind of
a an irony that we have an antithetical
presidencies back to back a progressive
and a starkly conservative and we need
to let history adjudicate you you
brought up facts but the prior
administration prognosticated that you
need a magic wand to carry off what
Trump promised and Paul Krugman said the
stock market was going to tank and
Barack Obama said you can't drill your
way out of oil shortages and Larry
Summers I think said 3% GDP that was a
fantasy so it was all a fantasy it was
all yeah I'm gonna do all these things
yeah and so what let history decide
we're only 18 months into the
administration
sited the facts Obama should stop
relitigate in the past and be impure let
it play out and look decide yeah we'll
see we'll see in another two years I
mean maybe and all this will go away
certainly hope it doesn't Howie I want
to focus on the media aspect of all this
it really is quite something because a
lot of things they accuse president
Trump of thin-skinned insecure
narcissists narcissist boasting I mean
the fingers always pointed back at you
I think the Buddha said and it seems
like when you watch Obama yesterday he's
cool he's kind of little but back in the
chair yeah fun and so but this seems
like a lot of that going on here Barack
Obama got the most gushing press since
George Washington and clearly he misses
it and he misses the spotlight but he's
got to give a rest to this golden oldie
about Fox News that record is so
scratched up from being played so many
times he completely ignores the fact
that they're all these liberal media
outlets that make Trump bashing a 24/7
business model now I'll give it a little
more slack than you do because all the
ex-presidents talk up what they think is
good about their record but a lot of it
is the indirect shots at Donald Trump he
doesn't mention Trump's name since the
midterm we all know when he talks about
well you know nobody near me was
indicted he's talking Paul Manafort he's
talking my plan you know this is the way
he is trying I think to make himself
look better
why is offending half of the population
a good strategy for expanding his
influence into 2020 for instance I mean
it's the same thing they they always do
it's what Hillary did with the
deplorable zhh he got away with it with
a bitter clinger thing because he was so
good as a politician but they're not
many Obama's we're gonna come around and
be an Obama type person but Fox talk
radio like they have pretty much
everything they're the universities they
have most of the churches yeah they have
most media outlets still today most all
newspapers for the most part and that's
still not good enough
that's what's stunning to me right well
I think that you know Barack Obama's
view of the world is simply that where
he still can't believe that Donald Trump
the election he can't believe that
people all people don't love him which
is what they accused Trump of Trump gets
mad if you slide him Trump if you
criticize him even slightly Trump
reminds you of it right but he's
probably
that's what Obama does I'll be feeling
slightly emboldened by the fact that the
Democrats the house and he said AHA now
they're gonna see that was better than
they remember yeah we'll say Austin this
is what the president said speaking of
the no indictments he made this comment
let's watch not only did I nobody in my
administration got indicted by the way
was the only administration in modern
history that that can be said about in
fact nobody came close to being indicted
partly because the people who who joined
us were there for the right reasons
oh really I mean let's go through the
list maybe short of indictments Austin
fast and furious IRS scandal Solyndra we
blew five hundred million dollars
taxpayers money Benghazi we have a dead
US Ambassador Susan Rice went out there
and said it was a tape that cause he
caused the deaths the VA scandal a
disaster tens of thousands of veterans
denied care Shinseki resigns in disgrace
oh you know of course we had the OPM
hack by the Chinese which was a
nightmare and and we could go on and on
and on so yeah no one was indicted maybe
that's more you know it's more related
to the fact that we had Loretta Lynch
and Eric Holder in a Justice Department
I don't know that's just a speculation I
don't know it seems like you got to kind
of focus your fire there Laura you're
really what fat what are those what are
those fat I will say is well well I
would observe two things one I agree
with you I and I agree with with our
with our discussion there I prefer if I
would prefer a President Obama and all
previous presidents kind of let it go
let the battles be fought not by the old
administration let the new
administration even if you think they're
making mistakes I don't think it's right
for the president to be the one out
leading personal attacks you saw with
the Bush administration George Bush he
went to the ranch
Dick Cheney took a totally different
approach he was very critical by name
you know going after administration and
I favor the bush approach I wish Obama
were not being as critical as he is that
said I don't think that it's an
exaggeration
when the president says there are more
people being indicted and there have
been more scandals on the Trump
administration then there were under the
Obama administration understand what
you're saying
technically that is true however what
he's intending all of us to take away
from that and oh we have this ethical
group they were only in there to do good
stuff well I was trying to do good stuff
I'm not saying you love you I totally
love you I started I started from the
spot that I agree with you I don't think
that the president should be the former
president should be saying that about
the current president yeah vdh yeah I I
would just say I don't think that's
quite correct because the verdicts not
out Eric Holder was the first District
Attorney General to be held in contempt
of Congress Lois Lerner pled the fifth
amendment and we don't know what's going
to happen with the Obama FBI CIA NSA and
DOJ officials because the verdicts not
out on Bruce or eight to ten FBI
officials have already been retired or
reassigned or maybe facing indictment
the saga of James Comey and John Brennan
John James clapper is not over because
we're sitting we're looking at a
situation where a presidential candidate
hired a foreign national to find dirt on
her opponent and that dossier was seated
among top officials of the Obama
administration we haven't had an
accounting ethical or legal yet and it's
coming and we didn't even have a chance
to put that in our graphic Victor so you
actually win the graphics of war tonight
thank you so much great guys great
segment